hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast clinical applications and
strategies using procalcitonin to
improve patient outcomes presented by
dr. Eric cluck director of critical
services Swedish covenant hospital
I'm Cindy Valdez Roberts and I'll be
your moderator for today's event we're
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by labyrinth is
sponsored by Abbott Abbott is committed
to helping you live your best possible
life through the power of Health for
more than 125 years they've brought new
products and technologies to the world
in nutrition Diagnostics medical devices
and branded generic pharmaceuticals all
creating more possibilities for more
people at all stages of life in more
than 150 countries 94,000 Abbott team
members are working to help people live
not just longer but better and for over
40 years
Ovid has committed to delivering the
highest quality products to serve our
hepatitis in vitro diagnostics community
for more information please visit
Abbott's calm before we begin I'd like
to remind everyone that this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time during
the presentation just click on the green
Q&A button located at the lower left of
the presentation window and type your
questions into the box that appear on
the screen well answer as many questions
as we have time for at the end of the
presentation also notice you're viewing
this presentation in a slide window to
enlarge that window just click on the
screen icon located at the lower right
if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing the presentation just click on
the support button at the top right or
use a Q&A button and let us know you're
having a problem this presentation is
educational and thus offers continuing
education credits click on the button in
the bottom left hand corner and follow
the process to obtain your credit
I'd now like to introduce our presenter
today dr. Erica Gluck dr. Eric cluck
received his medical degree in medicine
from New York Medical College in New
York he completed his residency at Beth
Israel Medical Center in New York City
and a pulmonary fellowship at the
University of Utah School of Medicine he
currently serves as a director of
critical care care services and chief
academic officer at the swedish covenant
hospital in chicago illinois in addition
dr. Gluck is a professor of medicine at
the french university of health sciences
at the Chicago Medical Center dr. Clark
is part of many professional societies
most notably he is a fellow of the
Society of critical care medicine the
American College of Chest Physicians and
the Chicago Institute of Medicine he's a
member of the American Thoracic Society
Alpha Omega Alpha and the American
Society of law medicine and ethics he
has presented lectures and authored many
peer-reviewed articles and chapters in
the field of pulmonary critical care and
has been in practice for more than 20
years more recently dr. Gluck has been a
leader at developing and implementation
strategies at an institution to reduce
the risk of sepsis in critically ill
patients join me and welcoming here
today welcome dr. Gluck well thank you
for that introduction a pleasure to be
here and I want to thank Abbott for
inviting me to talk on a subject that is
very near and dear to my heart so
basically we're going to talk about the
clinical applications and strategies to
use a relatively new biomarker to
improve patient outcomes in sepsis my
disclosures are that I give lectures
about biomarkers for sepsis for multiple
different companies but I am NOT an
employee of any of them
okay so these are the contents we're
going to talk a little bit about the
background for biomarkers in sepsis
diagnostic tools to make us better at
identifying patients and with infections
hopefully earlier we'll talk a little
bit about how we can use these
biomarkers for more appropriate usage of
antibiotics and finally we'll end with
some case studies which I think will
hopefully elucidate some of the points
and I'm going to make during this talk
substance is a big deal
there are about 1.6 million people who
are diagnosed with sepsis every year
translates to one every 20 seconds in
the hospitals it is the leading cause of
death when you look at causes of
mortality and costs substance is a
unbelievably significant problem it's
increasing every year the cost of taking
care of patients is increasing every
year looking at somewhere in the range
of 20 to 30 billion dollars estimate for
this year or over the next three to four
years so quite significant mortality
rate 21.5% measured about a decade ago
the currently estimates of about
fourteen point seven percent but that
includes all forms of sepsis patients
with severe sepsis and septic shock the
ones who are more likely to end up in
the hospital and the intensive care unit
average mortality for those patients
somewhere in the high 20s to low 30 but
even when you think about fourteen point
seven percent that's that's one in six -
one in seven people with sepsis
succumbing to it so why is this a
problem and why can't we do better well
first of all we are doing a lot better
if you go back five decades when
antibiotics and I see use first
became significant the mortality rate
for septic shock and severe sepsis was
in the 80 to 90 percent range so we are
doing better but why can't we do any
better the problem is is that we have
this very complex relationship with
bacteria we coexist with about five
trillion that's what that number works
out to be five trillion bacteria we have
eight trillion cells of our own and so
there is almost as many bacteria in our
body as our own personal cells if we
have this great relationship though with
them the good guys help us we they are
essential for survival they help with
digestion they help with manufacturing
certain chemicals that we cannot do on
our own they actually protect us from
more evil bacteria and if we keep the
situation in check this is a perfectly
mutual beneficial relationship they
won't harm us we won't harm them
everyone coexists with great day times
the problem is is that this system
doesn't always stay in check and this is
not the only way that we can become
infected we don't always become infected
from bacteria that are in our system in
fact most people would have not even
thought about those most people talk
about the infections that come from
outside the one you get from somebody
who you're at a party and all of a
sudden they coffin all sorts of bacteria
viruses get expelled and becomes
airborne and are potentially causing
somebody else an infection back in the
day as we like to say infection was
based mostly on a gut feeling doc went
up to the bedside looked at the patient
got a couple of rudimentary lab tests
and decided that the patient was
infected corroboration this was very
poor there was very little objective
evidence nobody really understood the
sensitivity of specificity of white cell
count and emia fevers everyone just
assumed they were very good correlating
positive cultures was very poor only
about one in three
patients with bacterial sepsis had a
positive culture of any sort and so
basically if the clinician thought you
were infected you were infected and if
you got better with antibiotics that was
a success for the antibiotics if you
didn't then it was a failure for the
antibiotics but nonetheless you were
still infected as it turns out we
finally learned in the 90 1990s that
those biomarkers the white count fever
and Vandermeer were not as specific for
infections as we really had hoped they
would be
the second problem with antibiotics was
that they were basically prescribed by a
regimen
people received a device for seven days
ten days 14 days and then they were
stopped
so antibiotic regimens were prescribed
they weren't titrated and and we now
understand that this is not optimal
patients present with a different load
of bacteria in their body and therefore
might need therapy for a different
duration of time patients also have
their own personal medical history and
as such they may be better or worse at
defending themselves against an
infection and so we need regimens that
are based on response not based on a
prescribed duration and the previous
tests that we used were not able to
discern how long to give antibiotics for
in an individual person the severity of
an infection varies from person to
person most importantly it all depends
on the immuno competency of the patient
and when I talk about immuno competency
I'm not just talking about whether a
person has a disease like leukemia or
lymphoma that might adversely affect the
person's ability to defend themselves
against an infection yeah we those are
part of the process but people have
recently had an infection they're immuno
competence he may have not have been
fully just restored yet elderly patients
patients who are malnourished patients
who have alcoholic problems all those
patients may have a different level of
Imperial competency and therefore may
respond to an infection different
how long it takes for the patient to
present to a healthcare provider may
also change the severity so a pneumonia
could be very easy to treat if the
patient presents early on much more
difficult if he or she waits at home for
three or four days because the size of
the bacterial burden will vary and this
will vary depending on how long the
patient takes to present how that how
many bacteria the patient initially got
infected with and how well the all their
own immune system can defend itself
obviously the site of infection is
important there are certain areas of the
body where infections are relatively
routine and the body can handle them
that would be the GI tract there are
other places where the body can't handle
them at all that would be the cerebral
spinal fluid area so meningitis and
encephalitis are very bad pneumonia is
somewhere in between and of course we
already talked about the nutritional and
functional status is being very very
important in how well somebody could
defend themselves against an infection
so the duration of antibiotic therapy
should be dictated by response so we we
need something to tell us what this
response is we also now know that white
cells and the other biomarkers that we
used are not sensitive nor specific
enough to clearly identify all the
patients who have infection and those
patients who don't have infection in
fact one of the criteria that we use
we'll talk about this a little bit later
service criteria it turns out two-thirds
of the patients have these criteria but
only 25% of patients in the ICU are
infected so how does the body know when
there's an infection going on well this
is a depiction of the cell and over here
is the cell wall and on the cell wall we
have these respectives they're sort of
like antennae fluttering in the fluid
between ourselves the interstitial fluid
and they're looking for bacteria living
bacteria
dead bacteria parts of bacteria innards
of bacteria and they there are actually
12 of these receptors eight of them are
external for them an internal they will
respond by creating a biochemical
reaction when they encounter a bacteria
this whole idea is to turn this cell
into a bacteria fighting machine but
also to warn other back other cells in
the neighborhood that they are under
attack so they send out a signal to
other cells nearby and that's where
these inflammatory cytokines come as you
can see over here that's where they come
into play
these will respond and they will do
things inside the cell to turn it into a
killing machine and also leak out of the
cell and go to other cells to tell the
other cells that there is an invading
bacteria in the neighborhood now the
problem that the body has is that we
have bacteria throughout our body in
different situations we already talked
about these guys over here these are
called commensal bacteria these are the
guys who are our friends and as long as
they are in the right numbers in the
right place they really can't do us any
harm in fact they help the only time
they could become problematic is if we
change the environment and that allows
them to grow out of proportion to what
they should when that happens or if the
barrier to that is changed like you see
over here well then they can actually
invade our body and cause us of
infection you may have had a friend or a
family member or know about C difficile
infections C difficile is a bacteria
that's in our colon and typically does
us no harm unless the environment in the
colon has changed and then it it can
become a devastating infection and you
can see that the body's response to this
is pro-rated of course we have these
pathogens that can get into us
some of them are very weak they require
some additional change in the
environment to cause an infection
and then we also so those are the
faculty pathogens and in fact a lot of
people think that those are the ones
that are the bacteria that people
encounter in the ICU and stuff like that
those are the bacteria that require
debilitated hosts for them to get going
the pathogens over here are the ones
that you can get by writing next to
somebody on a train or a bus and they
cough on you and so sometimes we sort of
treat those because they're so easy to
get outside the hospital as less
important than the ones that you get
inside the hospital but nothing could be
further from the truth and then you can
see that the response of the body to
these bacteria is significantly
different than the previous responses
and again there is this dose response
curve the body recognizes initially just
a little bit of cell wall and then there
is this response that is limited if they
see dead bacteria then the response
starts to increase if they see live
bacteria then you can see that the
response is really quite robust and then
when you have these pathogens that can
produce toxins as well then the response
is really quite traumatic the body
understands this and what we need to do
to really understand when there's an
infection is to tap into this resource
there is an infection when the body
thinks there is an infection and so if
we could look into these chemical
responses and find one of them that we
could measure easily and accurately that
would help us identify an infection when
the body thought there was an infection
because when there is an infection as
you can see here the bacteria excites
these pathways are talked about on the
cell and a whole chemical reaction
occurs leaking stuff out of the cell and
causing further proteins
remain in the nucleus and these
responses are very very specific to
those bacteria so not only do we know
that there's a bacterial infection but
the body sort of knows which bacteria it
is that is causing the infection in
addition there to this nuclear response
is as you can see on this slide here the
release now the release of these
substances basically is what gives you
the fever that chills the elevation and
the white count the change in cardiac
function all of those changes are there
in an attempt to defend against an
infection the problem is that those same
chemicals to some degree are released
whether there's a bacterial infection or
whether there's inflammation as is
depicted over here so here when there's
inflammation we get the same response
and so initially the body doesn't
discern the difference between a sterile
inflammation and a bacterial
inflammation in fact it responds just
like the fire department does if you
pull the fire along the fire the fire
guy gets on the phone he doesn't ask you
what kind of fire it is he doesn't ask
you if it's a big fire a small fire
electrical fire gas fire or anything
like that he just says where's the fire
and they send everybody there and once
they figured out what's going on they
will decide who needs to participate and
who does not well that's exactly what
the body does whether there's federal
information or bacterial infection the
body responds as if it was a bacterial
infection because that's the thing that
can do it the most harm and that's why a
fever a white count an elevation in band
count are nonspecific because the body
responds to that whether there's an
infection or not so once again what
we're trying to do is tap into these
biochemical pathways because those are
the ones that are much more specific
infection so as I was saying the the
immune system doesn't always
differentiate between sepsis and damage
one because it's a bad evolutionary
mistake to allow bacteria to reproduce
rapidly without defending against it and
number two it doesn't make a lot of
difference if we waste some resources
initially eventually we can get a signal
that it's much more significant
sensitive so what are we going to do to
tap into this well initially
procalcitonin was identified as a
precursor to calcitonin which lowers
serum calcium cancer and calcium low
that you might get from eating a meal
that's rich in dairy products
as it turns out procalcitonin has a use
that is much more significant and
actually predated this it is one of
those chemicals released by the body by
the cells specifically in response to
bacteria it does not respond to viruses
it does not respond to protozoa it
doesn't respond to any other infecting
agents except bacteria and some fungi
which have been able to fool our body
into thinking they're really a bacteria
so for all intensive purposes this
procalcitonin signal identifies with
high degree of sensitivity and
specificity bacterial bacterial
infections it has been demonstrated over
the last two and a half decades to to
give us a dose response to the severity
of infections when the infections are
very localized the levels are just
modestly elevated less than point one is
considered normal
so in local infections
you almost cannot discern a signal
because the levels are so close to
normal as they would be very difficult
statistically to discernment as the
local infection spreads and becomes more
significant the levels will become
clearly elevated most people consider
0.5 0 to be clearly elevated and then as
you progress to sepsis and severe sepsis
and then ultimately septic shock the
levels get higher and higher so not only
is this a signal of infection it also is
a signal of the severity of the
infection and it is a signal of severity
infection not based on what the
clinician sees in the patient but based
on what the body perceives is going on
and the body is a much better observer
than the clinician now you have to
understand the kinetics of this
biomarker to understand how to use it
there are other cytokines we talked
about them in general that are produced
during an infection aisle 6
aisle 10 and TNF are prepackaged in the
cell and they are released virtually
immediately as you can see here the time
line they go up almost immediately to a
level that is detectable procalcitonin
and the other biomarker CRP they don't
go up right away there is a delay so it
is possible for a patient to actually
present early in sepsis and have a
normal PCT level or CRP so we need to
get two levels of PCT at least 6 hours
apart in order to be sure that the
levels are negative but here is the
beauty of PCT unlike the other
biomarkers that we talked about aisle 6
will disappear very rapidly as will
aisle tenant E&M which means if the
patient presents late it may not have a
signal
that we can see anymore so PCT and CRP
becomes signals that start a little bit
later but lasts as long as the patients
infected and so they become very useful
in identifying patients with sepsis in
this chart here we did a sensitivity and
specificity analysis of the different
biomarkers here we used procalcitonin C
reactive protein
l6 and lactate now let's dispel with
lactate lactate is a wonderful biomarker
although it looks poor in this study and
that's because lactate is not specific
for infection lactate is specific for
perfusion defects so when a patient has
hypoperfusion of organs the lactate
level goes up that may be sepsis but it
could also be heart failure it could
also be trauma and so that's why it
didn't show great sensitivity and
specificity as you can see here il-6 and
CRP did pretty well
CRP has a problem in that it is also
slightly less specific because it will
go up in sterile inflammation of the
biomarkers that we're testing PCT had
the best receiver operating
characteristic so it had the best
sensitivity and the best specificity
okay we talked about all these different
kinds of descriptions of infection just
to go into a historical perspective back
in the day people finally understood
that those biomarkers that we're talking
about are not as specific as we thought
they were for infection and so dr. bone
in an article that was published in 1991
came up with the concept of serves the
inflammatory response syndrome which if
there is an infection present denote
sepsis if there is no infection present
denotes sterile inflammation so
basically not all patients
who have an elevated white count fever
Mandy Mia low blood pressure tachycardia
tachypnea
are infected if they are then they have
sepsis if they are infected and they
have organ failure we call that severe
sepsis if they have low blood pressure
and elevated lactate levels we call that
septic shock this has recently been
modified last year I guess it was 2016
and they changed it a little bit to make
it more specific they thought and
sensitive and so the server's criteria I
left out because sirs doesn't denote
infection infection denotes infection
infection in organ damage is now
considered to be sepsis and then
infection organ failure with low blood
pressure and/or
an elevated lactate level denotes septic
shock and the big difference in the
lactate level between the older and
newer criteria is the level in the older
criteria was four-and-a-half millimoles
and now it's two millimoles in reality
though these are nice for classification
and for identification of risk but
what's the most important thing is not
that to a clinician is is the guy
infected
does he have sepsis and sadly neither of
these two schemes tell us that we have
to figure that out for ourselves and one
of the ways to figure that out for
ourselves is to measure biomarkers in
the new criteria when I'm not going to
belabor this we use specific criteria
for organ failure - denotes substance so
that everyone will be on the same page
when they're identifying organ failure
this is the sequential organ failure
assessment or the sulfur scale that's
how we identify that ok what about
the newer guidelines with respect to
identification and usage of antibiotics
and patients with infections so for the
longest time in the United States we lag
behind our European brethren they have
been using biomarkers for antimicrobial
stewardship as well as identification
perceptions for at least a decade before
we got going but finally now in the
surviving substance guidelines for 2016
we can see that the expert panel
believes that the measurement of
procalcitonin levels can be used to
support shortening the duration of
antimicrobial therapy what does that
mean it means that we can now titrate
antibiotics to a specific patient and
infection as opposed to just some global
algorithm that is supposed to be okay
for everybody which we know it's not
most importantly when the levels become
very low they now suggest that we can
use those levels to discontinue empiric
therapy so if we've started the patient
on therapy we now can look at sequential
procalcitonin levels and when they
become very low typically ninety percent
of peak level we can stop them in
addition
we can use negative PCT levels to avoid
the use of antibiotics and people who
are not infected and we can also use
them to decide when patients who are
infected are not responding
appropriately to therapy
so typically procalcitonin has a
half-life of about 24 hours and so if
we're treating a patient appropriately
this biomarker should disappear by 50%
every day if it does not it would
suggest that there might be an infection
that we're not treating adequately again
they recommended the use of this
biomarker for treating patients with
hospital-associated infections and
ventilator associated infections so
there were separate papers dealing with
just infections in general and then H
caps and bats as well so current
guidelines management of patients with
hospital-acquired and ventilator
associated pneumonia is we can use it to
discontinue antibiotic therapy we can
also do it to implement an antibiotic
stewardship program so that we can
overall reduce patient exposures to
antibiotics and they are now when we
look into the critical care society
finally in 2017 and they have approved
the use of procalcitonin in their
surviving sepsis campaign guidelines
again reiterating what the IDSA and said
joining the duration of antibiotics and
for the discontinuation of antibiotics
especially in circumstances where we've
never actually been able to culture the
organism from the patient so most of the
time procalcitonin is used as a
corroboration for infection but
typically clinicians will start
antibiotics
even before the levels come back and
even if the levels initially are
negative because of the fact that they
can lag six to twelve hours be until
after presentation for patient however
when the PCT is negative two times and
these measurements have taken at least
12 hours apart typically they're done
every day so not 12 hours apart just
once a day then antibiotics are
typically discouraged in typical
protocols and data has suggested that it
is a very reasonable clinical thing to
do besides telling us when to stop
antibiotics procalcitonin can also help
us prognosticate so that we can
understand whether patients are going to
do well or poorly this was a paper that
I authored with Phillips out shoots and
others where we looked at the decline in
procalcitonin levels and as a function
of survival and what we found was that
when the levels declined at 72 hours by
80% from what they were at their highest
the mortality rate for severe sepsis and
septic shock was only 10 percent if the
procalcitonin levels did not decline by
80% under those circumstances the
mortality rate was 33% so it was three
times higher when the PCT levels did not
decline this was the basis for the Moses
study some of the data I will be showing
you here but I just wanted to go through
some other data to show the benefit of
procalcitonin in the American literature
over the last decade these are multiple
different studies where we looked at
either discontinuing or continuing
antibiotics with lower respiratory tract
infections based on PCT levels and so
here what you can see is that in the
vast majority of
the studies PCT demonstrated a benefit
here is the one of the exceptions this
study over here by Kristofferson did not
show benefit but all the other studies
did show a benefit for procalcitonin
this was a study that also I possibly
should have presented this before now
basically this basically tells us why we
cannot necessarily wait for the
procalcitonin levels to become positive
to start antibiotics because what this
study showed was that once the patient
presents to the emergency room there is
a seven percent increase in mortality
relative seven percent the mortality
rate only goes up by seven percent of
what the patient would have been so the
mortality rate for that patient was
twenty percent it goes up by one point
four percent but it does that every hour
and so we cannot afford to delay
administering antibiotics but if the PCT
levels come back negative
we will DC the antibiotics typically
that's 24 hours so early recognition of
sepsis is really important in order to
improve the outcomes for this patients
but sometimes patients will present with
elevated procalcitonin levels in whom
somebody did not expect the patient to
have an infection okay so this is a a
substance algorithm that was promoted by
the Moses trial so patients who are
diagnosed with severe sepsis and septic
shock they looked at the change in PCT
levels over the first four days if the
levels changed by less than 80 percent
the patient had a high mortality rate
risk if the PCT levels changed by more
than 80 percent there was a lower so
this was the Moses trial this is the
trial that got the FDA to
to increase the statements that could be
used about procalcitonin and use it
increase it's used clinically we can
look at some additional studies that
show that P CT guidance significantly
reduces the duration of exposure to
antibiotics for patients with sepsis so
this this was a meta-analysis and you
can see that using these cutoff levels
you can actually significantly reduce
exposure without increasing adverse
events obviously that would be an
importance I this was for everybody on
antibiotics and you can see that the
antibiotics exposure starting at day
three was statistically significant and
it stayed significant till almost a
month later these are data from
randomized controlled trials that show
that there was no adverse association
with reducing antibody exposures under
those circumstances so you can see that
although they worked patients were
exposed significantly less antibiotics
there was no increased mortality can we
use this around the hospital yeah this
study showed that you can get the
benefit if you use it in the IDI
anyplace in the hospital gives you a
similar benefit in community acquired
pneumonia there was a benefit acute
exacerbations of COPD possibly one of
the most significant benefits these
patients always have caught a lot of
them have chronic sputum production and
then they get short of breath it is so
difficult clinically to identify whether
there's an infection so these patients
receive antibiotics typically five to
seven days and we knew that only half of
these patients actually have bacterial
infections we just didn't know from the
get-go
well procalcitonin this biomarker can
actually help us identify that and you
can see the dramatic reduction in
antibiotic exposure in acute
exacerbations of COPD which is still one
of the most prevalent
things that we see in emergency
departments okay
sorry about I don't know if you see that
yellow thing there you weren't supposed
it anyhow PCT in my hospital I was an
early adopter I I did this because so
many patients were coming up from the
emergency department on in antibiotics
and my colleagues wanted to continue
them but I could not see that the
patient had an infection so we were
looking for something that would help us
and so we became an early adapter so
we've been using it this slide is
actually a little old it's now nine
years and we we draw about 200 PCT
levels a month and used to be solely in
the ICU but now it's used in the
emergency department as well as on the
general medical floors okay so those are
the introductory remarks and I know that
took up a good portion of the hour but
we're going to go through some some
cases these are not really exciting sexy
cases but they do demonstrate how to use
the biomarker
okay so first patient presents nausea
vomiting abdominal pain did some liver
function tests they're abnormal they
were obstructed people are believing
that this patient has ascending
cholangitis patients elevated no left
shift lie face was normal which helped
rule out the possibility of pancreatitis
so the patient gets resuscitated with
some fluids antibiotics the start
started cultures are obtained and of
course we're not going to get results on
these cultures because we don't do PCRs
at our hospital probably for 48 maybe 72
hours so let's do some bio market
evaluations okay so this is what the
biomarker evaluation look like on the
initial presentation you can see that
the PCT was initially point two it was
low and
the lactate level was elevated okay so
based on the presentation would we
suggest that antibiotics or working on
this patient or not why don't you guys
respond now and I think I will get a
real-time poll and how long after the
onset of antibiotic beginning should we
discontinue the antibiotics and I guess
the choices that you have in front of
you are from day one to day five so if
you guys could submit that and then
we'll go on and see what happens okay
initially the PCT level is negative the
lactate level is high and as we
resuscitate the patient we see that the
lactate level disappears pretty quickly
so you can see that within a half a day
that's what point five that I mean the
lactate level returns to normal so right
now at twelve hours into our
hospitalization we have a negative PCT
and we have a normalization of lactate
now 86% of you guys wanted to continue
antibiotics because you thought they
were working and and I think that's
quite a reasonable conclusion and about
half of you wanted to continue
antibiotics for at least five days the
other half actually pretty aggressive in
discontinuing the antibiotics but look
what happens on day one so 24 hours
after the patients in the hospital we
actually repeat the PCT and now look at
it's 10 despite the fact that lactate
level has normalized
but of course to lactate and PCT are
looking at different things
procalcitonin is looking at whether the
body thinks it's infected lactate is
looking at whether you fixed perfusion
and you did perfusion is great infection
still ongoing
this will stay elevated until we get
adequate antibiotic levels in the
tissues to force the body's response to
to get rid of the bacteria and so in
fact you can see here that the PCT
levels are actually the same 48 hours
later but now you can see on day three
there was about a 50% reduction on day
four a 50% reduction and on day five a
even greater reduction and so those of
you who thought that stopping
antibiotics and a five would be a great
idea that would be okay and in fact one
could argue that day four might be just
a little bit too early because there's
only about an 80% a little bit less than
80 percent decline there but now you can
see the difference between the two
biomarkers one is talking about the
adequacy of perfusion one is the
adequacy of infection control
okay so not to belabor the point
we gave the patients antibiotics
resuscitation made the patient
significantly better patient actually
had a great outcome okay so now we have
two cases which I call case to scenario
one in case to scenario two because the
two patients presented almost at the
same time four hours apart they had
almost the same history but quite
different clinical outcomes so the first
patient was a female was showing us of
breath some hypoxia patchy infiltrates
on chest x-ray the white count was
elevated there was a little bit of his
ships to the left she had some sputum
production no subjective fever okay so
now we get some biomarkers and the
biomarkers demonstrate to us on day one
that the patient has a negative PCT and
a positive lactate level
okay well still Clippy pneumonia
seems like it might be heart failure
based on the x-ray and clinical scenario
but can't not treat her at least
initially because the infiltrates and
the elevated white count for an ammonium
we're going to allow the PCT to help us
identify what is really going on in this
patient and so 24 hours later we repeat
the PCT and you can see that it's 4.2
I'm sorry the lactate level is 4.2 the
PCT is negative okay so we have now two
PCT levels that are pristine 24 hours
apart probability of infection less than
2% stop antibiotics lactate levels
elevated this patients into mark failure
so this patient does not need antibiotic
therapy this patient needs therapy for
her heart okay
presentation it was another woman a few
years younger nonetheless basically with
the same story almost identical chest
x-rays difference was when the sputum
did show a little bit of sputum
production and so we're going to pull
again here first
what would this pattern indicate when we
look at it initially we have a negative
P CT and a positive lactate but at 24
hours we now have a positive p CT and
the lactate has improved so would this
suggest a bacterial infection a viral
infection from pneumonia or do we still
need additional workup if you guys could
vote now that would be great okay the
second question that I'm going to ask
about this does this patient have severe
sepsis
this one's easy either yes or no and you
guys could respond to that one as well
okay well this patient was started on
antibiotics and you can see that there
is a nice decline in PCT over time and
this indicates to us that the patient
has had an appropriate response at this
point in time the patient was
transferred out of the ICU but still on
antibiotics there there was there was
still significant infection present so
we did not stop antibiotics but here is
the beauty of this these two patients
had almost the exact same clinical
history the chest x-rays were almost
indistinguishable one of them had just
heart failure one of them had pneumonia
one needed antibiotics and got it the
other one didn't need antibiotics and
only got antibiotics for 24 hours let's
see how you guys did okay we all
identified that this patient had a
bacterial infection
and we did quite well there about 66% of
you guys thought that and 61% says the
patient had severe sepsis and that would
be correct because the patient actually
had septic shock because the lactate
level was elevated and the patient did
have an infection so good good work
nicely done
maybe you could teach my fellows that
okay case three today history of
diarrhea and fever the patient had
recently undergone a revision of hip
surgery patient was exposed to
antibiotics for 48 hours to prevent post
off infection she presents with a normal
white count but with a left shift a
temperature to 101 and a hot rate of 107
so she has all the service criteria and
some criteria to make us think that she
might be infected abdomen was distended
and tender she had dilation of the small
bowel we are now suspecting that this
might be an antibiotic induced C
difficile overgrowth and infection and
in fact these are the PCT levels that
you will now see initially she presented
with a PCT level of 16 way.i I mean less
than 0.1 is normal so this is very
significantly elevated 160 times normal
okay
the lactate level was okay it was one it
was not abnormal at all
the patient has started on antibiotic
therapy for c-diff and the white count
goes up to eighty nine thousand I'm
sorry the PCT goes up to eighty nine
this is okay for 24 hours after
appropriate therapy the PCT can rise and
it will rise to the level that is
commensurate with how sick the patient
really is okay so one two eighty nine
this is a pretty sick person if you
remember that dose response curve then
it shows you early in the Elector
this person is way up there but we do
see that there is a response it goes
down to 64 then it goes down by half but
then over here it only goes down by
about a third and then here it goes down
only by a quarter and actually here it's
going up this should never happen we
were very concerned right between day 5
and day six when the PCT is not
responding appropriately something bad
is happening the patient ended up having
a perforation with massive peritonitis
soiling of her abdominal space the
infection became overwhelming with
multiple different organisms and then
you can see on the 8th the level went up
to 199 and finally to 99 and sadly the
patient expired
okay last case this is a patient who
presented with urosepsis oh I'm sorry
this is just a rehash of the previous
case okay here we go we have a patient
with urosepsis symptoms were frequency
and dysuria urinalysis was positive
white cells bacteria leukocyte esterase
and nitrates were positive okay so we
bring the patient in Tania's healthcare
unit because as you can see the lactate
level was very significantly elevated
and then we'll put the patient in the
septic shock range okay
and so we resuscitate the patient next
day the PCT didn't go down very much but
as I pointed out this is okay this does
not necessarily mean a treatment failure
lactate as you can see did respond very
nicely but here's the problem at 48
hours the PCT should be declined by 50%
and it's not and so the things we
consider here did we miss the
appropriate infection maybe this was in
urine tract infection we're treating it
with the incorrect antibiotics or is
there a protected source is this an
abscess is there some reason that my
antibiotics cannot get to with their
bacteria are to kill them the the levels
go up even further on day four we get an
ultrasound and we find that this is a
protected focus we find an abscess in
her kidney so there was a perinephric
abscess we sent it down to
interventional radiology the patient's
abscess was drained and we bring her
back to the ICU afterwards and I guess
for some reason I am not getting the
slide which would demonstrate that the
patient had a very nice up was not
getting that slide I I apologize what
would have happened
on the next slide would have been that
the patient had demonstrated a very nice
response to antibiotic therapy with a
decline of PCT of about 50 percent a day
until the abscess was completely drained
and the infection was completely gone
so to summarize what we have now for the
first time is a biomarker which doesn't
look at the macro response of the body
to inflammation and or infection but is
a very specific cellular response to the
presence of bacteria in the environment
and this response increases in response
to the intensity of the infection so
that it can tell you how sick the
patient is at presentation when the
antibiotic therapy is successful the
signal disappears with a half-life of
about 24 hours and so that you can
actually monitor the response to know
whether your response is effective so
you don't have to rely on the fever
curve which may be difficult to
interpret because of antipyretics or the
white count which always was difficult
to interpret because it seemed to
disappear way faster then the patient
was getting better we can titrate
antibiotic therapy specifically to the
response of this patient and then
finally if you think the guy's infected
but the procalcitonin levels are
negative times to at least spaced by 12
hours then your impression probably was
incorrect and you can stop antibiotics
right then and there so we now have a
tool that can help us look into what the
body is responding to how they're
responding how appropriately we are
treating them not from external signals
but from internal signals thank you for
your attention
and I would be more than happy to handle
any questions that may have arisen
during this talk
dr. Glock thank you so much for your
informative presentation we will now
start the live Q&A portion of the
webinar if you have any questions you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the green e Q&A button of your
presentation window type your question
into the box that appears on your screen
and click the send button will answer as
many questions as we have time for so
let's take a look at our questions from
our audience members now doctor look our
first question coming in is what is the
protocol or clinical algorithm that you
currently use your practice to manage
substitutions so if we have a patient
who presents with a reasonable clinical
history of sepsis the protocol is to do
adequate fluid resuscitation draw
procalcitonin levels and start the
culture of the patient and then start
the patient on antibiotics using an
empiric regimen based on the site of the
infection we then do serial
procalcitonin measurements to one
identify whether in fact this was an
infection and the response so if we have
two negative P CTS then we actually
discontinue antibiotic therapy the
pharmacists at our hospital will go
around we'll evaluate and look at the
PCT levels and if they are negative they
will put a stop order in antibiotics if
they're positive they'll keep the
antibiotics going until the PCT levels
are less than ninety percent of what
they were at their peak we use this
protocol in the ICU and also on the
general medical floors we also use this
protocol for the early identification of
sepsis in our patients so in the event
that the nurse has a patient - white
cell count comes back elevated on a CBC
or the patient develops a fever or
tachycardia or other signs or symptoms
of an infection the nurse on the floor
has the ability to order
a CBC a lactate level and a
procalcitonin level so that these data
can be acquired more rapidly so that
when the physician arrives at the
bedside to help evaluate this patient
with the nurse these data are readily
available and better clinical decisions
can be made
thank you dr. Clark and here's our next
question from our audience
how has implementation of PCT improved
patient outcomes so two things one that
is published one that is not yet
published the first thing that's
published is what we found out that
we're using a lot less antibiotics and
we figured out why we're using a lot
less antibiotics because we have a huge
number of people who are started on
antibiotics but are stopped at 24 hours
when the PCT levels are negative five
years ago eight years ago ten years ago
that could not have happened those
patients probably would have gotten the
full course of antibiotics mostly
because a negative culture doesn't mean
the patient is not infected so they
would have gotten the antibiotics so we
are we're down probably about 50 to 55
percent in our antibiotic usage number
two data that we are now accumulating
and should have ready for publication
shortly is our c-diff rate has gone down
significantly in the ICU we were getting
on average 15 to 18 cases per year of
c-diff we're down to four and the
initial analysis demonstrates that there
is a significant correlation with the
c-diff in patients who have gotten
serial PCT levels and in those patients
who and antibiotics stopped so these
data will be ready for publication very
shortly thank you doctor luck and thank
you audience member we have a wonderful
active
audience today our next question is any
are there any correlation between PCT
levels and g- and g+ orga organisms as
the source of substance so turns out PCT
responds more vigorously in gram
negative organisms only because the cell
responds more aggressively for whatever
reason - gram negative the cell has the
toll receptors that is equal for both
grandpas and gram-negative but there is
in addition and a little polysaccharide
receptor on the cells and LPS is only
from gram negative so there are I there
is another set of receptors on the cells
just for gram negatives and both of
those will stimulate PCT production so
there seems to be a more vigorous
response to the gram negatives and gram
positives GI infections have the highest
response as far as levels pneumonia in
between your na tract and skin the
lowest so it is dependent also on the
immuno competency of the tissue and
since the GI tract is has to be
tremendously immuno competent because
all the bacteria that are nearby when
it's not surprising that that has the
biggest response thank you so much
and here's our next question how do you
explain the negative PCT level at day
one for all three patients casein is
presented considering that a rapid
increase would be expected so I
specifically picked those those cases as
a teaching point what I don't want
people to think is that a single
negative PCT level means there is no
infection and so I only picked cases
where the PCT level is negative that
presentation however over the course of
the nine years that we've been using
and other people have recorded the exact
same result in an average hospital
community type hospital about one-third
of your patients will present with a
negative PCP level two thirds will
present with a positive one at the and
when they come to the IDI or to the ICU
or whatever so although it would appear
from my slide presentation that that was
the universal situation it actually is
the minority of situations but it does
help me make my teaching point which i
think is a very important one that in
order to exclude an infection you need
to PCT levels at least 12 hours apart
thank you doctor like and here's a
related question during really the early
part of your presentation we were trying
to confirm whether bacterial infections
exist but PCT levels are still low how
often would you recommend testing PCT
during the first 24 hours wait since the
person is going to get antibiotics no
matter what are the first dose and since
the beauty of antibiotics now is that
they have such a long half-life and we
don't have to give very many of very
many doses of them I only measure the
PCT every 24 hours
now the arete eclis there might be a
circumstance where you might want to do
one at 12 hours let's suppose you had a
patient with meningitis and you really
needed to know whether it's bacterial or
viral and the first PCT was negative
because the mom brought the baby in for
instance let's say very early that might
be a circumstance where you might want
to test more often than once a day
but since the half-life is 24 hours once
you've established that the person is
infected you do not need to test PCT any
more often than once a day thank you and
thank you audience for our active
participation our next question comes
from across the world is there an
advantage to initiating antibiotic
treatment
a patient presenting with elevated il-6
if one could get il-6 npc t levels there
would be but il-6 is a relatively
nonspecific inflammatory mediator as
well if for instance you had a trauma to
your leg your il-6 levels would be
elevated whether or not there was an
infection but if the il-6 levels were
elevated and you were waiting for the
PCT levels to become positive at least
that would tell you that there was some
degree of an inflammation in the body
and that would make it more likely that
antibiotics was going to be the right
answer but il-6 TNF are very nonspecific
very similar in scope to c-reactive
protein but even more globally
responsive to almost any form of
inflammation where C reactive protein
typically responds to a inflammatory
pattern that is lymphocytic induced
thank you and how do you address or
balance the misuse or abuse the PCT
usage from a lab point view well in the
big deal about abuse of any lab tests is
the cost
fortunately the cost is very small
second lab time
the test is automated so it's not a big
deal as far as extra lap time so here's
the point if a patient's on antibiotics
then there is absolutely no good reason
not to do PCT levels at worse don't
corroborate you're doing the right thing
at best they'll say oh this patient
doesn't need
buttocks or this patient you can stop
the antibiotics today you don't have to
wait till tomorrow the day after and the
cost of the test relative to a day of
antibiotics makes it almost a no-brainer
it's much more cost-effective to
measures PCT level serially than to use
clinical judgment with antibiotics alone
and and with stopping antibiotic therapy
early based on the PCT result leading to
antibiotic resistance no actually we
think it's just the opposite basically
antibiotic resistance comes from a
genetic fluke bacteria exposed to an
antibiotic they are trying to defend
themselves they're making all these
proteins and eventually they hit the
right one and they become the dominant
bacteria and so now we have a resistant
organism if you only expose them to very
short amounts of antibiotics because
they are not infected then the
possibility of that bacteria becoming
resistance is actually decreased so we
think that one of the communal benefits
of using this biomarker would actually
be just the opposite a reduction in the
potential for resistant organisms and
would you recommend having PCT on every
patient who presents in ER for suspected
cestus sepsis
if you are a discerning ER doc and you
think that they have suspected sepsis
absolutely it doesn't help the ER guy
that much but it helps the guy who's
going to be taking care of him after he
leaves the ER I mean if the PCT levels
negative and they send them home and the
doc looks at the guy he has to know that
the PCT level was negative this person
may have a syndrome that is mimicking an
infection but is not and if the
patient's admitted then we already have
a baseline level so that we can see if
the patient's responding to therapy
but as far as the decision-making for
the ER guy they are still going to have
to use their clinical judgment because
they're only going to have a single PCT
level when the patient presents so
they're going to if the patient has a
low idea I mean if the clinician is low
index of suspicion then a negative PCT
may be enough to stop not to give
antibiotics in the first place if the
patient has a moderate in you know index
of suspicion and the levels elevated
well that's going to push that index of
suspicion to very high so yeah I think
the ER guys need to use their clinical
judgment obviously this will help them
make better decisions and doctors what
are the guidelines that are recommended
to use PCT and diagnostic substance in
ICU yeah actually the original
guidelines from the FDA were all about
ICU patients and they have now been
supplemented by the IDSA guidelines and
the SCCM guidelines because the original
guidelines did not talk about
hospital-associated infections and
ventilator associated infections but
they did always identify patients who
presented to emergency ICU in in
prognostication of who was sick and who
is not based on the initial levels that
were obtained thank you and here's
another question regarding guidelines
beside the surviving substance
guidelines will PCT be incorporated in
any other governing guidelines example
CDC guidelines I do believe that since
the FDA has approved this these these
statements that they will be part of the
government guidelines what we're waiting
to see is whether the CMS guidelines
right now the CMS guidelines to tell you
what you have to do in the emergency
department and elsewhere when you
identify patient it must be infected
they are not part of those guidelines as
of yet lactate is
dct is not but those guidelines were
created a year before the FDA approved
these additional claims for PCT so we'll
have to see I think that they will be
included but I can't be on a percent
sure thank you so much we have time for
one more question
our next question is how does PCT use
differ between an adult versus a
pediatric patient population it really
shouldn't neonates that's a different
story when people and when baby is born
the immune system goes through very very
dramatic changes for the first 72 hours
so the guidelines they are very
different but the pediatric and adults
should respond exactly the same this is
not something that you that you gain
once you go through puberty or anything
like that studies and Pediatrics has
shown that it's just as useful in
pediatric patients as it is in adults
the only thing that's different is the
type of infections that kids get and the
levels that you might consider abnormal
in in them as far as I know point 5 is
still the threshold that most people use
as reasonably positive to the point
where the likelihood of false positive
is small so I would assume they're using
the same levels in Pediatrics but I
don't take care of those kids so I don't
know for sure but there the data is very
significant in that it should work just
as well in kids as it does in adults dr.
Clark thank you again for your
presentation and audience thank you so
much for your live participation we want
to let you know that your further
questions will be answered via email dr.
buck did you want to provide the
audience with any closing remarks before
we close our presentation today I think
I gave a nice little summary before we
did the question and answer so
you know I'm good and really glad that I
got the opportunity to speak to you guys
today and I hope you enjoyed the talk we
did and thank you again for your
presentation and your important research
I'd also like to thank lab roots and
Abbott for making today's educational
webcast possible before we go I want to
let everyone know that today's webcast
will be available for on-demand viewing
through April 2018 you'll receive an
email from lab roots letting you know
when this webcast will be available for
replay please share that announcement
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event that's all for now
and thanks everyone for joining us we
hope to see you again soon goodbye